notre région est entre mer et montagne
c'est le paradis soyez rassurés j'ai
trouvé la solution pour que notre
village rembourser toutes ses dettes
comment ça
non si madame le maire me solennellement
promis qu'elle fera tout pour que vous
vous sentiez comme chez vous suis pas
certain que ce soit très heureux de ce
fait là bas pourquoi c'est la grand
place du village
oui il ya le monument aux morts la photo
de guerre perdue comme accueille ces on
aurait pu trouver plus rien on fonde
font pas aussi ne faut pas aussi aussi
mais voilà on dire isolement c'est les
voitures mais il ya aussi le côté
romantique tout ira bien qu'on va
essayer je pense que vous et nous c'est
le mélange idéal
nous sommes passionnés
waouh vous êtes rationnelle voici
allez-y
passez pas vrai son but
[Musique]
ce qu'on appelle un jumelage riz signal
rost un os
[Musique]